given the massive critical and
commercial success of 2011's the Elder
Scrolls 5 skyrim a sequel seems like a
sure thing I'm Lucy and welcome to your
here's hoping it's not a five-year wait
games for news updates while six game of
the fantasy series is not yet in active
development but there's de marketing
executive Pete Hines has come forward to
say the studio will make the game into
time he said on Twitter the Elder
Scrolls six isn't in development we
simply said we would make it eventually
a sixth game in the franchise also came
up in an interview Heinz recently gave
to MMORPG he said they're an incredibly
talented studio of creative people
they've now made four games in a row all
of which were named game of the year and
they have a right to decide what they're
interested in working on next and which
direction they want to go I know what
they're working on for the next decade
and I think all of them are things to
get excited about four different reasons
but once they come out folks will enjoy
them for what they are as the lapa
thursday game studios is working on if
it's not a new main line Elder Scrolls
game the studio is cooking up three big
and crazy projects according to director
Todd Howard although he's since gone on
to explain that comments I should have
never said a number because we have so
many things you could add it up in
different ways you could say it's bigger
or smaller they're a long way off I
think the larger point was no one should
expect to hear about those games anytime
soon we always overlap projects and just
have more going on now than we have
before so what would you like to see
from bethesda game studios or from an
elder school six if it ever happens let
me know in the comments below i'll come
by me on twitter i'm at least james
games and for more on the elder scrolls
make sure you keep it gamespot
you